hey on destiny and I'm Jarvis am too I'm
heaven and today we're gonna be trying
something Korean and American Southern
Fried Chicken I am from Houston Texas I
live in k-town I am NOT an expert on
Korean food but I love it I am a
military kid so everywhere in nowhere
but I did do an extensive amount of time
in Korea and I had a very southern
upbringing so I know good American fried
southern chicken when it's in my face
actually I smelled it we walked into the
room I am from New York a lot of my
family are from the south so I grew up
being a lot of southern good food I was
originally born in Korea and I go back
there time to time to visit last time
went to Korea I went to this fried
chicken franchise I wanted to order
grilled chicken so I asked the waitress
do you guys have any non fried chicken
she stops like five seconds just like
how is chicken not fried back of the
line sir
so my understanding on how Korean fried
chicken came to be is during the Korean
War when they had the black soldiers
over in Korea they weren't just about to
be like oh yeah we'll have seasonless
food so we get to Korea and we're like
KATUSA odyssey we got you and so we've
introduced to them how to make properly
fried chicken slavery slavery yeah but
there's obviously a stereotype that
black people like fried chicken
I like fried chicken there are some
people who don't like fried chicken it's
time as for me and my house we eat fried
chicken I think for a Korean fried
chickens a little less heavy it's a very
juicy and very crunchy and it's really
thin if there's a lot of flavors unique
there's like sweet sweet and spicy spicy
this regularly interesting so with
Southern Fried Chicken I don't think
it's too many flavors yeah either you
got original or you got spicy I'm
excited yeah I mean I feel like you've
had the American version of Korean fried
chicken okay well I'm hoping that the
one that we today is pretty thick
I hope so it better I will let y'all
know immediately
I wore pants that could expand very
purpose if they bringing us food is good
food and I'm just gonna run with that
we'll see what happens if I taste it
it's actually but I will let y'all know
like I won't be like I won't do that I
don't think I have had a pan like
southern style fried chicken cuz I wanna
go to Korean fried chicken let's try
whenever when I want to eat fried
chicken all right so we have some
regular baby wings okay
it's called B beings and we have some
red hot drumsticks from baby chicken
very popular franchise so this think of
as a non spicy and spicy I'm excited
this yeah so there's a reason thing
about the spicy and non spicy with
amongst the Korean Koreans would like to
eat one of each so we created a menu
where a plate includes both of them so
that's a very popular combo other than
Korean fried chicken industry also very
cultured
let's eat the most special feelings
first okay all right this is them very
juicy and that I will say it tastes good
I want the skin to be a little like
crispy ER yeah yeah but no let's go
there just a key ingredient in southern
fried chicken that it's missing if it
had that that's a sort of spice that I'm
not familiar with when I go back to
Houston but I mean it's still good
watch out damn bro they're certain fill
in your life that you just like wait
yeah you guys dive in I play this is
something that I've had before family
reunions just like a big tray at ease
sitting right next to the macaroni now
what I have been waiting for what I
cannot wait for you to as a matter of
fact I don't want you to try I just want
a witness you want to see my face whoa
it's not spicy like you think this is
like I'm spicy but it's like a little
sweet and you can see them the skin
music plays I think that's a sweet part
is that both sweet and spicy this is
life-changing
I like it I like it yeah I will say this
isn't the one that I remember having in
Korea but it is very very very close
I do I do like the regular Southern
probably went a bit better so find this
stake 5/8 nailed it so you know how
smash some of these are you doing it
right now yeah we don't gotta worry
about okay a little spicy I appreciate
this
I'm so happy to be a part of the video
thank you so much we have some fried
chicken from Dooley I'm excited for one
it's a black-owned implied they got my
money all right well we got my money I
can tell this is gonna be nice and
crispy nice and juicy yeah I think is
gonna be good that's right mm-hmm
it's always gonna clean the fine like
where the first place should be good I'm
not mad about it very good as usually is
what you might taste whenever you go
like a soul food restaurant usually you
got a side I like some greens mac and
cheese corn bread yeah that sort of
stuff this is also whenever you have an
event at like a predominantly black
church this is what the chicken will
taste like yeah yeah it's good it's very
peppery I'm a sucker for pepper a lot of
pepper the peppery flavor kind of
compliments to the a little bit of
dryness and the texture of the meat not
as noice very flavorful yeah I like this
I feel like you cannot put all chicken
in one category I feel like you can't
compare because you know two chicken is
the same this is why it goes so well
with like some macaroni or some collard
greens are like the same we are together
we got we have a party here yes I think
they happy we got we got a surprise I
didn't know we had sign bro this is all
ours is this what you're talking about
this is what I'm talking about it's not
just mac and cheese this is baked mac
and cheese this is a different ballgame
we don't want none of that stove top oh
that's that's really good are we missing
the collard green
oh wow well the good ol southern girl
with me loves southern fried chicken and
curry bruh I think I would have to stay
with the Korean fried chicken I'm sorry
my people I'm sorry can I just say that
I can't choose like they're both great
for different reasons I don't know yeah
it's alright so based on my mood today
which may change tomorrow I would have
to go with this and fried chicken just
cuz I was in the mood you know I just
visited home a few weeks ago so I'm
still a bit homesick but you know maybe
tomorrow also just like clean of food
yesterday's ask me again tomorrow I'll
probably choose the other one we'll see
you know no matter how I am Thursday you
know people say there's always room for
dessert yeah my case isn't always room
for Frenchy yeah it's really cool that
Korean fried chicken and southern fried
chicken is so different but it's like
the best version of those words yeah I
felt like the southern fried chicken was
very flavorful been done with the Korean
fried chicken it was like crunchy that
sauce they had on there boy it's so
juicy but I'm not gonna lie like if I
had to choose today which one I thought
was better I'm gonna have to say D
Korean project that sauce really wowed
me I don't think I've ever had that on
any fried chicken before it was good
good I'm rice I'm liking today
[Music]